[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
hey
[Applause]
hello and welcome back to the break room
or maybe welcome to the break room for
the first time this is a new show we're
doing here daily on new rockstars right
here on the youtube channel we're gonna
keep you updated about what's going on
in nerd news from our very own break
room yes we are live coming to you from
our break room where we eat our salads
where we enjoy our chips where we drink
too much coke zero this is it this is
where we like to hang out sometimes it's
a work in progress it's gonna be
changing all the time we're gonna be
adding stuff maybe taking stuff away uh
but i'm not alone even though i'm
talking all by myself i've got other
friends here with me i'm brandenburg he
right here next to me is jessica clemens
oh my god
oh my god
my name is
thank god it's on the teleprompter uh
we're also here with tommy bechtold come
on
let him know so thrilled to be here guys
thrilled to be anywhere that's on the
outside not concrete and steel bars you
know what i mean oh baby it's great to
be a free man again we sprung him from
jail and now he's here and also here at
zac
oh my god i'm thrilled to be sitting to
tommy bechdel's right and i'm thrilled
to be here with you america yes and and
continental europe wow yeah canada
mexican canadian
and let's be honest a few of you in
russia looking for an escape tonight
but folks we're not here alone okay you
know this is our first live break room
and we wanted to really give it to you
today so we got a very special guest
today uh he's new to the channel say
hello to eric vaughn
[Applause]
now get out of here
i just want to thank you all for leaving
a chair open yeah yeah yeah capital e
uh yeah it's like passover would you
leave the door open for
who do you leave it open for that
is it jacob i don't know you close the
door because the angel of death is yeah
you shut the door so they don't burn you
when you're sleeping i don't know what
that's keeping up that trend of zach
problem
it's making you problematic welcome
by the way eric no one believes the
allegations okay so no matter
was that me i thought that was someone
else
you're the one that's had that trial
right in virginia
my lawyers just say try to get him to
settle
eric's here to drop a grumpy and on all
of you uh watching today and yes we do
appreciate you guys being in the chat
we've got lots of fun stuff for you i
don't know what it is uh but if you type
uh exclamation point rules uh you'll get
a little
a hint at what you could do in the chat
what some of the options are but we are
we do have a a tip jar going today and
we have a special redemption that can be
done now the fcc won't allow us to curse
here on youtube i don't know why but we
can't afford it so if we raise 50 every
time we raise 50 you open up the swear
jar and we'll be allowed to give out one
sweet sweet swear okay a really good
swear and i should mention uh my parents
are watching and they already paid my
cell phone bills so no need to tip mom
and dad don't worry about it
but we have lots of stuff to talk about
today it's a huge week we're so excited
uh but we have like news updates for you
today uh we got star wars updates we got
a new look at the miss marvel's poster
uh keanu reeves possibly joining the mcu
what possibly uh some moon night romance
that was cut
and uh john watts is pulling out of the
fantastic four wow yeah all of that we
got some other director drama we're
gonna talk about brandon but now we're
gonna uh quasi begin after five minutes
it's the most fun for everyone
every episode is gonna start with
headlines these are kind of the you know
big part of this show is it's yeah that
oh we've got a headlines graphic run
that one more time i was talking through
it
we're going to cover all the news of the
day including stuff that maybe is not
big enough to normally make it to new
rockstars but it's still the stuff that
you want to know about you want to hear
about
leading off today as brandon just
mentioned john watts the director of all
the tom holland spider-man movies in
addition to a hyundai commercial that
eric had a blast breaking down one time
oh yeah yeah he felt like i was in the
car with him
he's announced he's uh pulled out as the
director of the upcoming fantastic four
movie
um he was set to kind of direct that for
the mcu uh but he's taking a break from
the superhero realm he's the quote from
him
um and of course yeah he directed uh
spiderman homecoming far from home no
way home i don't know i mean
that's a three for three success rate as
far as pretty fun great movies thoughts
on no more john watts doing fantastic
four i understand i recognize being
tired
i sympathize with being tired and he
also did like the short film peter's
to-do list so it's like what he's doing
all those all those spider-man things
it's like hey you want to jump on this
dude it's like dude come on please give
me give me a second he does other things
too he does like horror so let him just
do some other weird stuff also on the
chiron we have i think we have an extra
h and john watts his name if i'm not
mistaken right right right this is jay
john watts with an h is my plumber
and uh you know that one guy in la is
the smell good plumber john moss is the
opposite he guarantees a stink that'll
make it i got you i thought when you was
in an extra h i thought it was john what
john what that's why he's not directing
anymore he's so confused john john has
to have the h because
another headline uh jeremy slater is the
head writer of moon knight he's been in
the news a lot lately and he did an
interview recently where he said that um
the original love interest for moon
knight was going to be echo
and then through the kind of script
development process they realized it
wasn't a great fit and uh i guess they
you know the studio was like actually
we're going to use her on hawkeye and
apparently he was relieved because they
couldn't really figure out how to make
it work um
yeah that would have been interesting
she was great yeah
yeah i think that they both have to i
keep adding my two cents uh
my two cents that i think they both have
such incredible story lines that i don't
want them to muddle up each other's so
i'm glad that they were like we should
separate these two yeah the worlds don't
have to come crashing into each other
from every property right like we don't
need to have like well hawkeye had this
so then we tie this into this let
everyone just breathe a little bit right
take a deep breath
it's almost like they realize that uh
the deaf character might make more sense
in a matte fraction adaptation where the
main character is going through his own
deafness as opposed to a hero going
through d.i.d yeah i don't i don't buy
that story i feel like that was the plan
all along i read the article and it was
somewhere that they were like the marvel
studios were like hey put these two
together we like her and also we don't
know where to start her so it was before
she was supposed to be in hawkeye that's
when they were like oh we have another
series we can throw her in to get her
started it's a better show yeah
definitely better it's a better fit um
speaking of mcu testing
rumors well this is that wasn't a rumor
this is a rumor and this is we're
prefacing this this is a rumor okay
we're not reporting this as news um but
uh supposedly keanu reeves could be
getting his first marvel role
uh there's this rumor kind of
circulating uh that he's been attached
to a secret role that is not
um part of a disney plus series but it
is going to be a film in the mcu uh
maybe like you know like mr harry styles
showing up there in the pc of uh
of eternals spoiler warning if you
didn't see that maybe
six months ago oh you can blame what was
it deadline of variety
yeah you can blame varrock yeah i mean
real quick without spending too much
time on it who do we want to see him
play oh that's a hard question great i
mean it's silver surfer right maybe it's
just a point break fan and maybe
him
i think silver surfer or doom
would be good doom would be really good
it's a counter-intuitive move too
because keanu's associated with just
like low emotion like chill even his
john wick character is kind of chill for
being a homicidal maniac right but
putting that in doom would be that is a
fun what about what about a mr sinister
whatever would be tying to mr sinister
that was john hamm's role and he wants
it back that's right uh i think you're
all wrong he's clearly going to be mojo
yeah tv you're going to put him in the
fat suit in the chair
i insist you hire a 500-pound hacker to
play that role yes it's unfair to keep
catching i'm working on it guys i'm
working on it stop it
i should be playing wolverine
because i know we're not sick and tired
of that yet
uh another
age just like oh you're dead oh
um there's a new poster for miss marvel
which that that's you know the disney
plus series premiering at the beginning
of june um and it's cool oh you see it
on the screen right there it was in
celebration they released the poster as
uh uh was celebrating eid which is like
celebrated at the end of ramadan and of
course uh miss marvel is the first kind
of um uh
muslim lead character in an mcu uh
property disney plus series or film um
so that's really cool that was a great
graphic and a nice reminder
after moon night that's the next marvel
show we're getting it's right around the
corner i don't i don't want to uh i
don't want to cut back from that news
because that is exciting but someone did
say keanu reeves playing ghost rider
which could be pretty cool he owns a
motorcycle company right he literally
manufactures his own motorcycle does he
yeah so does the guy from actually this
might not be true
yeah
he makes the only ones that you can fit
a crossbow into that's true
and then
this is i don't know how i feel about
this news but uh marvel announced they
are flipping the release dates for the
marvels the follow-up to uh captain
marvel and quantomania the third in the
ant-man franchise originally marvel's
was going to open early 2023 february
quantum mania was going to be in that
july
uh time slot in 2023 they're flipping
those so we're getting quantomania in
february of next year followed by
marvel's in july and supposedly it's not
like a big strategic thing they were
just uh quantomania is farther along in
development it's going to be ready
earlier which i think is hey that's a
win better than
just delaying one and not moving the
other one up right like we still get our
fix baby
you guys all might be able to add to
this more it only slightly irritates me
because i'm just like oh you guys can
easily switch movies like that so that
means that the order doesn't really
matter i think it does matter and that's
why they switched it i think that's
something they figured something out
yeah or something in doctor strange that
they altered they're like we got to get
ant-man out first well
especially we know
kang is going to be in quantum mania and
they set up kang already and loki and
why delay more kane right like that's
true we want that connection gotta have
mccain
i think they want to have uh loki's
season two strategically come at a
certain time and that needs to be synced
up with quantum mania since kang so i
think the good news here is that we're
going to see kang in some trailer
sometime by the end of the summer which
that's great news for all of us that's
right yeah
yeah wonderful we don't have a time on
loki season 2 yet yeah sometime in 2023
i think they've started filming right
yeah what was the last thing we read
something about this just like last
weekend right now tell us in the chat
you know if you have insider info on
when loki sees the two's coming out if
anyone works for loki
the character not the show yeah yeah
yeah it's all canon yeah uh great okay
well that that we got more headlines
coming up later including some really
fun
uh [ __ ] talking uh director drama and i
might have just ruined this weird joke
well we get updated on where this square
jar is from our buddy old pal producer
dodson um
are we are we are we going into some
doctor strange and the most important
we have to address it we gotta address
the leak that came out yeah and that we
are not talking about that none of us
don't
we've never seen it no no i don't
condone it
and i would love it if you guys in the
chat also didn't spoil it for everybody
we have mods in there to make sure that
no one's getting spoiled um and with
that being said in the new doctor
strange multiverse madness trailer that
came out this weekend we see doctor
strange and american chavez busting
through like different world portals
what what have you it kind of mimics the
same site that we saw on what if when
vision ultron is fighting against the
watcher
um and we see a couple places that i
don't
like the keanu reeves i don't want to be
like written down for noted as like
jessica said this it's like we think
one being coruscant that's one star wars
from star wars yes go back and watch it
you guys you can find the trailer
anywhere it's just so small could this
be just disney saving money on cgi
what do we got in the back-up file
we also see what might be mustafar and
upon second look we think melissa bar
was in the what if episode with vision
ultron and the watcher when they're
fighting and jumping through portals
then we see the captain carter shield
bounce around almost hit dr strange and
then we see the what we're all freaking
out about the yellow chair with the
green sleeve in an old man's hand
which is who else but professor x from
the old school animated series right so
what is going on where can this what
does this mean for the animated shows
and tv
animated tv shows and movies what does
this mean for doctor strange does it
seem like it's just like a shout out or
are we actually going to get into it
well i uh i should let you all know as
soon as we are done taping here maybe
even before we're done taping here i'm
gonna have to jet out because the reason
i'm here in la is to see the premiere
the press screening of dr strange's
multiverse of madness in hollywood so i
don't know what the leaks are i will
find out in a couple hours what this all
means but to me this is similar to what
if i think this is why what if is
essential watching ahead of doctor
strange and multiverse of madness is uh
it gave us like a context in a visual
language of how the multiverse looks yes
and that can include other ip whether
whether it's something that looks like
cursor or whether it's like timon and
pumbaa
hanging out by water the simpsons right
yeah you've speculated yeah i think it
could all it could just be a joke i
think that's the idea the multiverse is
it breaks past our frame of reference of
what considers the what is considered
the media multiverse that we know that's
also the same i know this is your brain
thinking with also like everything
everywhere all at once like the same
introduction to like doing the
multiverse stuff i keep beginning to
think like oh it's going to affect
doctor strange but it's not going to
affect dr strange it's just going to be
it's reading us up for everything else
like now that x-men 97 is coming out i'm
like what the hell is this gonna lead to
this for like what's going on well so
just a real quick shout outs to our pr
contacts at disney and marvel for for
blessing our boy here thank you
for years for years we would never get
we we're on the outside
looking in now we're lucky just to get
an email response it was so nice of them
to include us in this and you know that
benefits everybody that watches new
rockstars because that lets us get
things like the breakdown ending
explained out on the channel that much
earlier it lets eric spend even in our
great editors and all of our researchers
and writers spend even more time on
those videos we know you all want to see
we get to put them out early and they're
really good and we're really excited
about it and i want to just once again
personally plead to the pr people
christian marvel
let me back into these
that was a one two maybe six time thing
that i went in there with the wrong idea
of how a movie experience should go and
i think it's time for us
to heal let's get let's let the let's
let the past die
speaking of killing it it's time for
mandatory fun
[Applause]
put the screen
[Applause]
photographic oh my god
this is too much power it's too much
power
it's my world now this is my special
time hold on to your hats and cats it's
time for mandatory fun this is the
segment where i force my friends to have
fun with me
it's my world now it's my sandbox and
i'm the one who makes the rules and i
get to have all the gi joes and you guys
get to play with the dollar store action
figures that my mom made me buy and i
play with your g.i joe
going to do this every day so you're
going to have to love it
more smiles biting smiles up we're going
to do it every single day today's our
first show and i thought we would focus
on celebrating some things that we maybe
didn't love at first because let's be
honest are you saying they don't love
this
what is that uh a brit above the
philippines says i've i'm calling 9-1-1
garth mack says oh no skulls carlos
raymond says this is the worst day of my
life okay anyway so
people say love at first sight i say no
no no no no love is patient
love is blind okay some things we give
it a try we watch the pilot
and it doesn't go as planned but then
over time
things change it's like beauty and the
beast you hold someone hostage long
enough they're gonna fall in love with
you as long as your house is enchanted
guys little stockholm syndrome so i'm
gonna go first set the tone here
breaking bad
when i first met you i thought you were
boring as hell
chemistry teacher selling a little
crystal meth in arizona or new mexico
been there done that
live that life okay didn't need to watch
it turned the pilot on six times before
i got through it
then something changed
i watched the second episode
and the third
and fourth
that little sweet bald head
i hated your wife but that was on
purpose
they wrote her to be annoying she died
good job anna gunn's a good actress
pretty soon i like jesse pinkman
i thought he was a fun guy badger skinny
pete the rest of the gang
before you knew it i was
seeing a therapist because the show had
destroyed me mentally it made me think
that maybe god isn't real
uh so much sadness so
the breaking bad
i'm the one who knocks and when you
answer that door
it's me with a dozen roses and one
simple message
i love you
just to be clear tommy each of us is
going to have to do exactly that yeah
and like i said every single day we're
going to have mandatory fun on this show
but today we're just talking about how
the first episode isn't always the
cleanest
got it all right it takes time to grow
it takes time to grow let's do next eric
is our special guest do you have
something i'll go i'll go um
dave filoni
and
the whole team behind clone wars
by the end of your series i was bawling
beautiful
a full meal left me satisfied no notes
but i gotta say first season episode one
trash fast
no not trash but a mixed bag
for sure uh when i first started
watching that show whatever was
2009-2010 i'm like this show's not for
me i'm a man
[Laughter]
yes talk to me i'm a man this show ain't
for me there was every other episode
there was a 3po getting his head swapped
with something else uh jar jar
was
falling down a flight of stairs and
proving himself not to be uh a sith lord
i wasn't a fan and i wasn't even a fan
of uh the animation at the time i wasn't
a fan of uh snips and sky guy i didn't
get it but man oh man that whole world
grew on me full redemption wow for the
clone wars
era of star wars history beautiful so
once we get to the whole arc everything
with maul coming back in but you know
what was so great about this show it
wasn't just maul it was every character
on that show got better and better so
stick with stick with clone wars because
by those final four episodes of
season seven
some of the best finest star wars
storytelling
uniform don't give up guys don't give up
don't give up right you know don't be a
stalker and don't harass someone but
yeah don't give up also i see people on
the chat yeah there's a conspiracy
theory this is pre-recorded this is not
pre-recorded
this is not pre-recorded gerk underscore
oh five five possibly be pre-taped
[Applause]
don't take anybody do you wanna go yeah
i can go um i'm scratching my mic um
you know
i talked a lot of crap about you
supernatural
let me tell you
um i talk a lot of crap about a lot of
shows that were on the cw still are on
the cw and i talk crap about but
specifically supernatural and you know
what
i judged you i judged you way too fast i
didn't move in with you i didn't share a
cat with you um i didn't take bites of
your food when you told me to stop
like i we didn't do those relationship
things there was a dance of me looking
at you and being like oh what do these
two really basic boys have to offer me
a woman
nothing and then
i realized it's not about two boys
offering me something
it's two boys in a supernatural world
it's demons it's a scarecrow that comes
to life every
other season and you have to feed it
someone that's hitchhiking it's about
insects that eat you from the inside out
i don't it's about a golem
freaking man that eats the heart out of
people at church at church this is
beautiful thank you and what do i want
more than that nothing so to you
supernatural to you jensen echols you
beautiful beautiful man more beautiful
than the burnett i said it um
and you know what
i realized mid talking about this um i
don't like your newer season so i guess
wow okay
my favorite thing about love is how they
keep calling it an experiment it's not
an experiment no it's actually i don't
think they understand the scientific
method speaking of experiment i think
i'll go now um i wanna i wanna speak to
a show okay that
probably a lot of people liked but it
took me a minute for it to grow on me
maybe like this show maybe you see in
the chat everybody else is loving this
and you know what it just feels a little
bit off to me well then maybe for you
you'll feel the same way about this show
as i felt about game of thrones oh oh
re-watch that pilot okay that's all i'm
gonna say and tell me that that doesn't
seem like
uh
the secret garden
or oh you know what i mean there's a
secret garden yeah
there's a tea house in pasadena called
the secret garden there's a lot of
british children okay there's a lot of
talk really about puppies at that point
they were just puppies okay a lot of
that episode a lot of that pilot is
devoted to puppy time incest and and yes
and it's like sean bean and a lot of
people you've never seen before okay
wait is it
it doesn't matter there's a little bit
of interest in that just like in secret
garden okay
we saw different versions of sticker
parts oh i'm talking about the secret
garden on santa monica boulevard
no secret garden is a club you guys it's
about a movie yeah yeah how do you think
i was talking about the world war one uh
um british uh okay no no no no you go to
secret garden on a thursday you're gonna
leave until saturday
on your point to come back to the
instant stop
uh that was beautifully shot
but i mean
i you know you didn't have me from the
pilot
but then
you know by the end of that i'm like
okay there's enough here oh the kid
falls down oh i'll give this a second
episode oh a little bit better a little
bit better and then by the end of that
first season you know i'm i'm in i'm
into the end regardless of how that end
turned out i was in till the end okay
game of thrones that's love that's
that's love is passionate love is wait
what are the patients loving it love is
passion love is blind
love is patient love is kind you is kind
you is smart
give him the ultimatum okay okay okay i
got i got i got mine i got mine okay
the expanse oh boy oh boy you know
television sci-fi i was done battlestar
galactic it was great i had a great
relationship with that didn't in well
but uh you know i wasn't ready for
another tv sci-fi series the book is
great they told me i'm not going to read
a book how many words are in a book and
no pictures
then i started finally watching the
expanse after bezos bought it and man oh
man what a good show you got in there
buddy great sci-fi gravity matters in
space is it possible
you can't heal because there's no
gravity this is crazy i've never
considered this concept before thomas
james what have you done to your hair
it's beautiful my guy my wife won't let
me get their haircut i'm gonna do it for
you my guy
crying watching episodes on my phone on
the bus embarrassing yes but man what a
good show you got there it's been on the
bus i really liked it uh it's great it's
gone now it's done but if you haven't
seen it please check out the experience
what what wow wonderful you know what
they come here for the nerdy news uh of
the content they love they stay for the
public transit and haircut talk that's
right
now listen to me
that was beautiful guys and you know
what else it was it was mandatory fun
play that graphic against mandatory
again yeah
we're doing it every day and it'll be a
different thing and no one can ever be
mad at me
eric just said yeah yeah yeah
that was a segment that was me deciding
oh i think i
wow looks like you're not getting your
water
it's like you're going to be fixing wow
wow well uh speaking of things you can
use to hide your shame we got our
friends over in the epic hero shops
hiding a lot of [ __ ] uh taking a look at
it or not tommy and i are both
rocking through
check it out over there uh
there's great new rockstarsmerch.com
is kind of the affiliate with epic hero
uh shop where they got uh we've already
talked about a little bit on the channel
but from the thor trailer the great like
trekker hat that he's wearing in the
trailer there it is
right look at that bad boy they
recreated it uh the new rockstar staff
did some zooming and enhancing uh so we
could figure out exactly what that hat
uh said and i think that's the only
place you can get it in the world uh oh
maybe that's just me speaking without
doing any research you just like made
everyone want to create their
[ __ ] like i bet you i could
make it well we'll beat you to it you
dummies
and and of course there's a great uh
wanda vision shirt there that's an
augmented reality shirt a cool uh fall
into the multiverse shirt there but
those would be totally appropriate to
wear to the premiere or to the opening
night of multiverse of madness and then
i just want to do one other quick plug
here new rockstars is on tumblr
tumblr now uh we've been doing a bunch
of cool moon night content on tumblr we
created uh follow uh new rockstars
official is the name of the account
jessica has been doing some really fun
content and uh um social media tyler
have both been uh posting uh clips from
the breakdown some kind of uh
special exclusive stuff tumblr's a fun
place to have like an extended
conversation about stuff uh check us out
there you probably already follow us on
the other social platforms get it get it
going on tumblr too yeah
if you're crying out loud yeah we post a
lot of butts
no we don't no we do not no i promise
[Laughter]
okay um back to some headlines here i
mentioned or i hinted at this before uh
we got news uh
the 10th movie in the fast and furious
how do you say it fast x are we saying
fast action
oh come on i like fast tense that's in
your seatbelt
that's okay thank you thank you however
you pronounce it uh i will be calling it
tenth movie in the furious franchise it
rolls off the tongue uh they announced
that the director of that uh justin land
who's directed multiple
members of that franchise including fast
five and maybe tokyo drift did he direct
that oh no anyways uh tell us the best
one he left
the fit like filming it just started and
he quit like a weekend yeah it's pretty
rare it's also very expensive when that
happens that cost the production a lot
uh and supposedly this is scurrilous
rumors that we love to spread here
because uh didn't like working with vin
diesel um he doesn't like doing those
weird vin diesel selfies where vin's
like very close in the camera and the
person behind him and vin's like
like doing a huge grip yeah oh yeah you
guys kind of just recreated it there
tommy and eric can you leave in real
quick
and then can you be diesel
bt's
something like that but hey good news
they already got a replacement director
uh and it's director of the ed norton
hulk movie louis le terrier i don't know
if that's how you pronounce his name
how do you say it
louis letterier
if it's wrong you guys can just yell at
boss about it it wouldn't be the first
time i got it
uh but he directed uh yeah the ed norton
hulk movie also all i think both the now
you see me
uh movies those magician movies um and
uh the transporter film so i mean hey
is anybody worried about fast and
furious movies having like narrative
cohesiveness i got you know what i like
to see the directors finish their vision
these movies aren't important enough too
they are kind of like they don't all fit
chronologically right isn't the third
one like technically take place before
the tokyo drift yeah yeah well and
people have died and people have died
and come back
we come for the crazy we come for the
great set pieces and i have full
confidence that louis terrier can
deliver grabbing him was a great choice
because of the transporter movies which
i am on yeah real huge
and great great card chasers yeah yeah
oh you already got hobbes wait right
yeah
which one's hobbs and which one is
is the rock
one shaw's statham the other shot i
believe is luke evans is the other shaw
oh are you joking
there's two shaws one is one is bard the
bear with the guy
you know the guy from the hobbit that
slays the dragon and then and then the
shaw brothers directed a lot of kung fu
movies
anyways uh on to some star wars updates
uh we got uh news this is very specific
but the obi-wan kenobi series that's
coming out in just a few weeks yeah 827
yeah first two weeks um it's rated nine
plus and now that's like the age
appropriate rating for the series for
reference mandalorian was rated 14 plus
because of all that full frontal
hormone
in the other room
what clothes are you watching yeah you
might remember if you don't remember
what he said
hey he's right he said full frontal mud
horn and that [ __ ] was
completely naked didn't have any pants
on him
he showed his mud and his horn
that whole frog lady on frogman sequence
goku lifted up the mud horn to get an up
skirt
stop it
stop it
this kind of makes me a little less
excited
[Applause]
these ratings are so crazy specific like
mandalorian was 14 plus book of boba
fett was 12 plus what was the two-year
gap between those shows it's the butcher
scene right
or the butcher's saying or it's that
those motorcycle kids not obeying the
lie you know you can't have them
but also didn't an entire tribe of
people get slaughtered
that's as heavy or heavier than anything
in the mantle but it was we only saw the
after effects that's true it's like in a
rom-com in the 90s when they would like
fall into bed and the next thing would
be them in the morning they'd be like
well that happened what happened
my question is when i was reading an
article about this they said that it was
released in the uk as rated as nine plus
does that have any difference for us the
translation well i will say europeans i
don't know about the brits but europeans
famously more cool with nudity and sucks
okay that's cool
[Laughter]
oh my god also i do love the clone wars
in bad batch we're six plus which i
thought we just established those are
grown man shows
you can't tell me a six-year-old's gonna
understand the significance of ahsoka
looking up at that bird the star wars
star wars rebels was five minus right
like you couldn't watch it if you were
over five how how young were the
younglings that got killed were they
like nine were they not even nine yet i
don't even think they were nine mr
skywalker
i'm scared
mr scott this is jeremy
mr skywalker's my father please tell me
[Laughter]
the editor for the series kelly dixon
tweeted that the series is almost done
which is good because it's about to
start uh but also of note i don't think
it had previously been announced uh the
direct the editor for that series kelly
dixon was the editor for breaking bad ah
the connection to tommy's uh earlier
apologies well kelly great job on
breaking bad a show that i
didn't give a good chance
okay okay the second thing
segment's over is everyone gonna bike
lock someone do a pull and just
strengthen i think he's gonna melt
someone in a barrel yeah also that
headline is like i'm almost done okay
stop asking me
uh also yeah tell my family uh i'll i'll
be able to talk to him in a week that's
right um uh the actor who played emperor
palpatine ian mcdarmid is that how you
pronounce his last name uh hinted he'll
be appearing soon do it uh the quote is
there's a certain show coming soon set
around the time i may have considered to
be very active
whether or not you'll see my physical
body i cannot comment on but you will
certainly feel my presence wow i mean we
talked about this
this is wikileaks we're speculating on
kenobi it's like yeah
what a thirsty comment like yeah i don't
know if you'll see me but you'll feel me
somehow
my favorite part about not spoiling
things for the actors is the hurdles
they jump to make sure they don't
because they also they're also
contractually obligated to promote too
right but they can't promote in certain
ways well he's been doing it because
that full paragraph was just like maybe
maybe maybe not even and now we're all
assuming kenobi right that's the series
he's showing up in but he also could
show up in andor right yeah which that
that's later this year right i mean he
could show up at any point in star wars
history right that guy yes
[Laughter]
so we we talked about this briefly in
the office once that didn't the um the
the the dp said that there was like no
mention of darth maul in ob1 originally
she was like the producers yeah the
director
yeah there was no thought of it so could
that lead to why he would be an andor
versus an obi-wan it's if you piece what
she said there to his statement of like
it might be a voice it might be this i'm
like well technically i guess he's not
in it like could he still
i think it's as simple as like he's the
emperor he's like he's spewing out
propaganda
they just like hey you did some audio
for a bad batch can you record some
audio or something yeah yeah they just
show up and they lay down a track and
they don't know what it's going they're
calling that freddie prinz they're
getting they're calling in all those
favors from these horse ghosts you guys
i want really quick to say hey i thought
we were talking about darth maul that's
my bad that was i have darth maul you
know what jessica we were all willing to
move on real quick and pretend like it
never happened back to the incest and
i'm allowed to come back
and you said this was pre-recorded yeah
by the way oh well we can't curse we
can't go down we can now we can we have
broken our 50 swear jar limit by it says
86.90 oh wow so we can almost we can
square like
i did i think i earlier you dropped an s
i dropped an s eric just dropped a sons
of [ __ ] okay so now it's just tommy
jessica and brandon owe the world a
curse okay and i just want to mention we
said it before this show will always
come back to incest okay
we will not we promise you we're here
every day uh i'm gonna say a very
special swear word in my family i'm
gonna say the worst curse word you could
say in my niece elise's house ding dong
dixon
is that a wrestler from there
is what we say when we can't say effort
or sit we say ding dong dixon so we
don't get in trouble with my mom okay
danisa prime it is not pre-recorded shut
your damn mouth
i see what you're saying we're watching
you live yeah take this may the fourth
you better be there yes queen three
emojis
[Applause]
this is why we had to send eric to san
francisco he's too angry
nobody can see but in eric's blue
dungeon where he shoots with his videos
the wall behind the blue screen just as
holes punched in the right
while we're talking star wars and while
somebody just mentioned may the fourth
we have a very special may the fourth
episode planned for the breakdown
wednesday and that person that said may
the fourth be with you jessica they know
yeah they know who i'm dressed there
might be there might be costumes there
might be
paraphernalia there might be specialties
there may be special guests visiting yes
oh yes
so definitely
if you watch if you only can watch four
other episodes of the show this week
make sure one of them is the break room
okay got another good laugh from john
the editor
i don't know if anyone else is watching
this but john is watching it he is
loving it um i have to uh bounce
everywhere
i gotta go but everyone should stick
around who knows when i will appear
again
i'm like
a magical wizard who is with you always
uh and i love you all so much i can't
wait to watch the show every day i miss
you all so much in the bay area so being
able to tune in with you every weekday
is going to be the highlight of my day
and i hope it's the highlight of all of
yours i'm going to see multiplayer the
men's dinner yeah
[Music]
take your chair take your chair take
your chair take
[Laughter]
on social media for the next few days
there might be some cryptic maybe some
informative posts
who knows but definitely if you don't
already follow eric voss well hey get a
life if you're not already yeah
but definitely
follow his car whatever i would
definitely follow him and uh and we'll
also be mentioning we are just real
quick while we're talking multiverse
madness which eric is going to see right
now we are all seeing it thursday night
okay we're going to be talking about it
all week friday
we're going to have kind of a
spoiler-free
discussion review something something so
depending on when you're seeing it now
if you're if you're not going to see
multiverse madness till saturday friday
night sunday afternoon whatever you're
cool that's cool we're not going to
spoil it for you on friday yesterday
monday
gloves are off baby yes we're getting
we're getting uh mom deep yeah yeah
we're going deep in everyone's mom on
monday okay listen to me
you you don't see that movie friday
saturday or sunday come on get cooked on
monday because you've still got to watch
sunday
to watch this show and have it spoiled
for you because you didn't because maybe
maybe your kids are sick you can't leave
the house i don't care anymore gloves
are off
knives are off pants are coming off soon
too
sunday's mom's day oh that's right
that's right take mom to multiverse
madness mom yeah your mother would like
nothing more than seeing number 26 in
the series of mcu films having seen none
of them before i'll tell you what
you want to not ever celebrate another
mother's day again
take
there's a lot of moms that enjoy an mcu
fling okay don't don't uh increase them
my mom but also the two of us never got
the curse um
okay
and this is our segway into the break
room breakdown
[Music]
golf claps golf club um
just as eric left we are gonna look at a
clip right now uh and we're gonna break
it down we're gonna talk more about it
um and conscious
relatability to mark and how he could
possibly be ruining it
even more not to mention the other
oddities of this flashback sequence like
us never actually seen the boys inside
that cave and never seen young mark
escaping from it and the fact that they
are in urban chicago within walking
distance of a heavily wooded area with
easily floodable death caves like say
street is a weirdly sparse studio
backlot no extras no traffic they didn't
even try to populate it it's exactly the
kind of set wand division shot on to
intentionally evoke artificiality i
think the bird bones are evidence of
konshu influencing mark's perception of
his past and instead konchu might be
planting in mark's mind a false altered
memory about how everything really went
down
i loved eric's uh theory there and and
sorry just gotta you're about to
introduce
look it's like
he feels bad
it feels bad oh my god he's so sweet so
sweet um no the the break room breakdown
essentially i should have started this
at the beginning is when we take clips
from um bosses breakdowns and we break
it down either a little bit more and
sometimes we find reasons to disagree
because i feel like you guys also have
stuff to say to this and to this
breakdown in particular what i really
love is the fact that we're not saying
that conscious is marked we're just
saying that he's been manipulating his
mind because he has been colonizing his
mind since the beginning but i think
this is nice to see this uh introduction
of like the fact that he's just been
making a simulation so what he has been
seeing from what mark's been seeing so
mark could have been living this
different life but contra is the one
that's molding it and making it look
like this making it so his mind is more
broken so with that being said did
kanchu manipulate mark's memories in
order to get him to be his avatar or a
what
yes i a i love this theory because it
just points out like we knew we had we
all suspected right i don't want to
speak for you but i suspected as a
viewer probably most people did that
like oh some of this is real and some of
this is fake or imagined or hallucinated
or whatever but like this theory is like
what if all of this is different degrees
of fake right or or or hallucinated or
manipulated like this show is built on
unreliable narrator yeah right
with the one caveat of i think there
have been some scenes without mark
stephen any kind of oscar isaac or
conjure character in them like layla
talking to her
or forger or whatever uh wait was it
deceptive that was her mom i didn't
think it was her mom
apologies on the week of mother's day
for miss labeling a mother um
or or like the arthur harrow glass and
shoe scenes expensive shoes without him
but like yeah all these scenes with mark
or steven like none of that could have
been real either right all of it could
have been like weird manipulated
memories whatever um what are you guys
thoughts on what's real and what's not i
think i want to go with what boss said
mainly because i don't want conshu to be
looked at as like
a hero does that make sense yeah i also
don't think forcing someone to be your
avatar is really and he didn't force him
but like he was gonna die so it's like
he didn't really give him that great and
then he's like just ruining his life
more so i don't want to see him in the
light of like he's a hero it's like no
he is he colonizes guy's mind he is
controlling it and he can't stop until
this guy dies basically so i do want to
see this bad part of khanshu where it's
like yeah
not everything that mark's been saying
is really what happened it's khanshu
really just do you think his brother
really drowned in this weird cave that
exists that we haven't
we're not supposed to see the death that
is true but like yeah this weird yeah
what did boss quality call it a stephen
king cave yeah yeah and it's like i
thought they were in new york but i
guess it's like chicago well does he
even have a brother you know yeah
what if that is like real
very strange to be like oh we're just
gonna go head out and you know mom says
we shouldn't go in when it's raining
it's like ryan you think mom would be
there on the jump to be like get out of
the cage yeah my mom would never let us
go in the rain and never in the game
do you think so do you think it's
possible that mark konshu the brain
killed layla's father do you think mark
actually killed layla's father or do you
think what voss said could be true
i i do think it's it's part of like the
good storytelling of this series we
could have just not seen leyla's father
die and not seen the brother die to save
this from a raiding issue of like
on-screen violence though there have
been a bunch of fight scenes where
people die i've applied a lot of them
not dying and like people getting shot
in the head has not happened per se but
um or
it is to add this ambigu ambiguity like
this did that really happen kind of
stuff maybe this finale will you know
show us some of these scenes from a
different angle we'll realize fight club
style there was just one dude punching
himself in the face in some of these
scenes
it's the whole show that we've seen so
far is it all part of getting mark to
accept the moon knight mantle like has
none of that like is he's in the desert
he's gotten shot by bushmen we assume
he's crawled to the statue and he has to
make the choice and this memory he's
shown he makes the choice really quick
right but has this choice been this long
thing of like look what you could have
if you are a moon knight you could have
these powers you could run around this
city doing a really crappy job
it's not a good salesperson
yeah maybe maybe it's not even maybe
it's not an easy sell maybe the body
rejects maybe avatar like a human body
rejects the avatar
like
for a long time before it can fully
accept it maybe it's like an aversion
you know like an exorcism like you want
the demon now yeah um there there was a
great super chat question here from our
our friend
headhunter711 asked like you know this
series is listed as a limited series
moon knight is listed as a limited
series so like do we think we're going
to get more moon nights here because i
will say it feels like
there's still a ton of story this is not
gonna complete a story this feels like
one long origin story yeah i don't know
like the rules like we we've seen that
like they're they're submitting this for
the emmys as like a limited series right
which seems to say like oh it's not
gonna come back but like could they win
an emmy if they wouldn't emmy could they
still win at me and then have like
season two be like sorry
inside this is producer john hi there
was a tweet that came out today that
would can people hear you john yeah i
think so hi hi from marvel studios that
was like hey tune in to the series
finale of moon night coming out
then that tweet was deleted and it was
updated to say season finale
[Applause]
i guess i guess elon hasn't fixed that
part of twitter yet
you can still delete your tweets
thank god you can delete well that that
feels like implied confirmation that's
gonna be more seasoned there has to be
well there doesn't have to be but it's
like there are so many things that we
have not explored and you and i hate
that they probably were like
okay people are probably gonna ask about
jake but
they're not gonna actually ask about
jake and so many people are asking about
jake so many people are asking about
jacob so it's like come on show them to
us yeah
we did we did a poll on the chat and you
guys seem to agree 62 said that kanchu
is manipulating mark's memories but we'd
like to get those numbers up we would
like to get those numbers up we want
them 99
we can't guarantee it yet there's 575
people voted in that poll thank you i've
seen enough we're giving the state of
georgia yeah
stop the count we got right ahead of
them by the way we didn't talk about an
earlier uh poll that ran do you think we
will see a star wars cameo in multiverse
of madness i hope not and now that
almost the exact same ratio 62 percent
said no
37 said yes if if if it's a cameo what
do you want as the cameo i thought
right oh
no no i want general grievous yeah then
dr strange goes hello there
hello there oh my god no
i mean if if doctors if multiverse
amanda is just a two-hour meme fest yeah
are we gonna love that or
i would love it because it's also what
boss said earlier where or maybe i said
more that i was just like i thought this
was going to be like this changes the
world of doctor strange but it's like no
it's going to change the world for
everything that he's involving himself
in and going through there's a new this
is i'm sorry i have to say it there's
this new animated series that's coming
on that they're doing a great job of pr
for where the entire television is like
every cartoon is being taken over by
this static and he's been showing up in
rick and morty it showed up in like uh
craig of the creek it's showing up in
like all nickelodeon to disney to uh
cartoon network shows and it is so good
that i want to see that happen with
doctor strange even if it's him going to
through star wars getting punched
through a star wars little world i'm
like show it to me show it to me disney
these are all your franchises go off
make them go through the simpsons um
jump through yeah your simpsons go
whatever you want yeah uh 808 chaku ass
or they pointed out that moonai episode
4 foreshadowed the end of episode five
thank you when therapist harrow quoted a
line from tomb buster
yeah is that the whole um uh
you can't reach the heavens without uh
like stretching down into the hell yeah
yeah like that that is weird and like i
still think there's a lot of with arthur
harrow the show the whole series started
with him the first thing we saw in this
series was him doing his little
his glass slipper uh if you will if you
will but also something i noticed like
on my third rewatch or whatever is when
he talks about like
oh i took the bus to get here when
they're in the the psych ward he says i
took the bus to get here remember we saw
him on the bus like in london so as much
as like kanchu is manipulating all this
i think whatever arthur harrow is is
like manipulating a lot of it and i
still think he's anubis
yes
that's what i i still think that also i
just want to call out i it was it
scrolled by a million uh comments ago
but somebody and i don't know if this
was purposeful or if this was a purely
genius accident they wrote like what is
this show and then they said god like
g-a-w-d space
amit
and now i assume that was just bad
grammar on saying gd but it's also like
the perfect joke for moon knight isn't
it god
damn it
god emmett
yeah they do that on inside marvel
where we answer the questions from the
super chatters so i don't know if that
was stated at the top of the show but
when i maybe didn't stay at the top of
the show that's our first show it's a
work in progress
zach's fault yeah no we're just you know
what this is a loose show guys have you
come here for the tight the tight
production of of an erik voss video the
elaborate concepts of an mt video you
know what we can't deliver on that but
god damn it we can deliver a lot of
heart yeah uh the occasional swear i
just i accidentally dropped another one
and a lot of fun
oh yeah i've been saving up my swears um
someone said what is it we can each go
for a question rick vape well here
ismail montoya asks do any of you
collect comics if you do which ones are
you reading prior to doctor strange two
prior pride
[Music]
i keep re-reading uh moon knight to find
every uh
answer like the answer to all my
questions and to
fail but it's still very good to
re-watch that read those and i'm also
just reading a bunch of manga so it's
not like i'm doing anything i just read
fables
oh yeah it's great
um i i have not been reading any comics
recently i have been re-watching the sam
raimi spider-man
a bunch which i know will not impact the
plot but it is just like speaking that
rainy language that style those shots
like i'm getting very jazzed for
multiverse madness off of that yeah uh
lwl3 or wall three i don't know how you
say these things uh wow three uh they
were asking what are the chances we see
kang and doctor strange and here's
here's here's what i'll say i'll use one
of my swears to say it not a [ __ ]
chance whoa that's a big swear that's a
big swear swear wow i don't think we get
any canyon doctor strange it's that kang
is like next i think dr strange is going
to be the end of some things okay we'll
be the next now we because we've had
multiple films come out with no kang
since loki is that right we haven't had
a lot of kang well all we've had lately
is this little symbol on the back of a
jacket yes in uh no dang king no dead
cat it's the no ken gang
well but we still seen like this
multiverse shattering right with the
cracks and the
the cracks and the venom and the how you
fling them things
the cracks and the venom and the silver
spoon a little boy
[Music]
apologies if i'm mispronouncing your
name there sergeant uh what are you guys
drinking coke zero baby all day and a
little bit of whiskers
um an americano that tommy brought it
yes thank you tommy i got a bunch of
hydrogen atoms and half as many oxygen
atoms
and you know what i'm drinking g fuel
not an official sponsor of this
yeah
sponsor
show
if you're watching
the show they get me they get me up and
they help me keep going
[Laughter]
[Music]
i want to i want to answer a question
here okay from my friend donkey teeth
good name donkey teeth good name
once again i want to mention that this
question is from
don't isn't that what i'm doing no well
there was donkey lips on
your shorts yeah i auditioned against
that guy one of their names on the
football football players is donkeys
yeah uh all right so donkey
asks
why did game of thrones make it seem
like the direwolves were gonna be so
important you know what game of thrones
did that with a variety of characters
and elements in that show why did they
make a lot of things seem important i
did i did you see the scroll by uh dodd
just throw it up here uh mar marley was
asking
y'all and i love the use of y'all yes
you all think marvel over shared in the
multiverse of madness trailer i i kind
of agree i'm like full style
you gotta get more specific with
trailers there's been nine trailers
that's the problem and i'm not answering
donkey keith's question
but i think there is a real age okay
what's your answer i'm sorry i'm sorry
dogs were to expect like the animating
the dogs were too expensive yeah the
only dog that they could really put time
into animating was uh jon snow's dog
ghost and then the rest of them they
were like ah we'll just kill him on
screen without
sorry that's right you know what
apologies to mr teeth
i'm sorry doc
dr teeth my apologies well going back
doctor tooth is he's the yeah
uh okay yeah for sharing i think yeah i
i you know we have to watch every clip
that officially comes out we will not
watch your leaked footage so stop
sending it to us
but every every little clip that
officially comes on the channel to watch
and it's like okay i'm so excited to see
captain marvel on this but or captain
carter in this yeah but like don't tell
me
let me be surprised
i will say this
for all they've given us they're still
alive there'll be a lot they haven't
given us you know what they mean or it's
a lot that won't show up and i'm going
to be upset about it
that's true a lot of the stuff they've
given us could maybe not be in the movie
maybe it was just morbius that had the
trailer that was like oh i'm going to
see this in the movie and then like none
of this isn't
the movie uh and i'm glad eric boss
isn't here anymore uh i'm sick of that
guy mainly because every time there's
like a new thing he figures out where it
goes in the movie and he's like this
means this and that means now i'm like
thanks boss you know what
eric's playing 4d chess and sometimes
it's nice to be playing czech you know
what i mean i'm going off sometimes i
just play tic-tac-toe sorry jasmine no
it's okay i get i i speak too quietly no
we're just i'm a baby we're just toxic
men
tell me about it so
no i'm joking they're not toxic they're
beautiful people the only toxic person
here is that so
going off of what brandon said earlier
about um are they over sharing i noticed
this question that was in the chat i
think it was a super chat i don't see it
up here but i'm gonna talk about it they
said did you see the trailer for um
don't worry my dog don't worry darling
yeah
the olivia wild star in florence pew
from mcu yeah harry styles also in the
mcu oh record gemma champ also in the
mcu
they're all uh the movie the trailer
dropped today uh it's so good in another
trailer that kind of over shares so be
careful watching it but also that's good
to know that movie
that is gonna be great now that i think
like that's an interesting movie too
because like we've talked about
obviously this show break room on new
rockstars we're mostly gonna talk about
the stuff new rockstars talks about mcu
stuff star wars stuff dc stuff right but
like there is a world if if it gets
popular enough if our fans are
interested enough that something like
don't worry darling which has some
sci-fi elements i think that's right
it's also kind of a thriller yeah
there's a lot of questions there's a
world where we can talk about that we're
definitely gonna talk about stranger
things the boys minions
that's right i mean roger grew if you if
you went down with groot you went down
with the break room you know what i mean
but it's the group crew
but the one of the great things this
show is going to give us the opportunity
to talk about things that maybe you know
we can't justify making a normal video
about on uh
the new rockstars channel but maybe we
can talk about it here on the break room
so let us know right in these comments
reach out to us via socials things that
you would like us to cover here that
maybe we we haven't yet been able to
cover on the new rockstars channel oh
the last of us is going to be oh thank
you to everybody who has donated today
yes yeah thank you so much for tuning in
you know this is our first uh official
live break room show we've done some
secret shows here and then we popped up
randomly on the channel and you might
have caught it but you know if you have
seen the earlier shows things look
different and they're going to continue
to look different this is our actual
break room right we're constantly moving
things around and changing it some
people might need to take a break at a
certain point we'll have to clear on out
of here yeah people are begging to come
have their lunch and we refuse to let
them eat their salads and of course
right uh this is a new show that is just
extra on the channel none of the other
stuff you love under rockstars is going
away eric is making even more breakdowns
uh empty and eric will be having and
whitney will have even more kind of
great theory videos and recaps and all
that kind of stuff this is just another
way for new rockstars to kind of
interact with you to cover the things
you love and it's all extra we're
growing and this is part of that growing
process yeah uh so thank you so much uh
our first episode yay hang in the bag
i would call it a success
thank you to everyone who watched thank
you to my family at home
really yeah and we'll be here every
weekday around the same time uh
broadcasting live talking to you in the
chat having polls having mandatory fun
doing break room breakdowns
talking about everything that we love
and having a great time with all of you
so make sure you tune in every day if
you miss it live watch the recap on the
channel be a part of something fun uh we
love having you and we can't wait to do
more of these shows uh for all of you
someone said hashtag more tommy yes
hashtag more time more tommy are you
going to say your phrase the the bill
that pays the bills i'd say this show
was gucci to much oh baby you heard it
here first folks it was gucci tumuchi
thank you so much for joining us today
uh we'll see you tomorrow we'll be here
let's have a great day
bye everybody
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
foreign